Happy Monday. I have a lot of stuff to clean and get done today,
as you can tell by my dirty mirror and messy room.
But this is a new little lounge outfit I got from TikTok Shop,
and my first time wearing it so far.
I love it. As comfortable as wearing pajamas,
but I feel like I could get away with wearing it out and about
if I had to dress it up, dress it down.
It also has pockets, which I love.
And I don't have very much going on up here,
if you know what I mean. So a lot of times these tube tops, like,
it's hard for them to stay up.
This one is perfect. It stays up,
but it's not really tight.
It's really comfy. Absolutely love it.
And I am ready to, you know,
just be comfy and get stuff done today. So let's do it.